it's cold down here i'm sure you guys
are warm wherever you guys are i hope
but uh
i just finished watching last night and
i have to say season four is probably
the best season of all seasons so
congratulations yeah it is
so much for that yeah the ending is so
great i mean for all three of you have
you guys kind of absorbed the amount of
obsession people have with this series
and how much people love it like does
does have you realized it
honestly it's a little hard to like
comprehend it sometimes yeah i don't
know especially with um covid we we wear
masks like whenever we go outside so
yeah it's hard to see like how many fans
there are actually out there but uh yeah
it's crazy i won't say the show blew up
over the the pandemic so i saw it we
were going out all the time and stuff
yeah
but yeah it was fun like running into
people they're like oh i love you brent
dimitri's arm that was awesome i was
like i hate you so much for what you did
to me
yeah they can't associate you're with
the character and andrew garfield i mean
come on i need this guy oh that was cool
right yeah that was his reaction
yeah oh yeah when he was like oh well
they knew who i am i was like bro i went
to your movie opening night like what do
you mean like ah
that was that was very very cool
will he be part of season five
um
my dad that'd be so cool
i don't know he's probably too young to
be my dad but that would be cool
i think that there's an older brother
maybe older brother would be cool older
brother be cool yeah no i think that
could be totally done i'm gonna give
myself a compliment and say we look
alike
yeah she's like you're both white yeah
it works yeah it works uh
you and jacob have a podcast together
congratulations on that project uh will
you be talking about season four on the
podcast
yeah you know you know we do throw in
tidbits here about cobra kai and all of
that obviously you know we can't talk
about it right now
but
but i think there is uh some fun to be
said about uh like what kind of goes on
behind the scenes and if people have
questions or whatnot but you know for
the for the most part it kind of is we
kind of uh don't really talk about cobra
kyle that much like it it really is uh
it's more like
you know what we can't right now really
because the season four is like the main
hot thing and we can't like but when the
show comes out we'll probably tell you
you up yeah
and i know we can't say but the ending
for your character show like
right like we can't say but were you
surprised when you read i was
all
the whole time reading the script but
you know what i and i i say this anytime
like a question like this gets brought
up because our creators really like are
so
they know everything and their
everything happens for a reason so even
when i see a cliffhanger like that i'm
like
i know i gotta wait till the over the
hiatus to figure out what's gonna happen
but
like i but at the end of the day like
they always uh come through with great
and creative ideas that you know keep
your keep the gears turning and keep you
like kind of keep you on your toes and i
think that that's that's what's allowed
us to kind of make it this far in this
journey for the show is the fact that
they're like
they maybe even if they do the expected
and it's in it's in an unexpected way or
if you know i think all of that is kudos
to them kudos to our creators our
writers they'll do a you know fantastic
job yeah they're brilliant gianni your
character is has evolved so well over
the series and i have to say is one of
the favorites everyone loves him i mean
does that res are you surprised how your
character resonates with so many people
definitely yeah i would say there was a
turning point for uh my character's
popularity because in the beginning i
always i would always get like oh your
character he's so annoying i just want
to punch him in the face i'm like oh
thank you very much i appreciate it um
but i think now that he's kind of
getting into the uh the karate um a
little bit more people are starting to
kind of be like okay maybe he's not you
know a total nerd uh still a nerd but
yeah there's hope for the kid um yeah i
love it you know and i love how many
people kind of identify with dimitri you
know i get people saying like hey you
know he really helped me get through
tough times i'm like yeah that's that's
what it's all about you know i i
identify with dimitri a lot a little too
much sometimes so i get it but um yeah
it's been awesome well congratulations
guys uh congratulations on season five
you guys are awesome and i can't wait to
see what happens with your characters
take care everyone
you